yeah I know APA on transparent so I
think I know what trans people go
through um you participated in a
trolling cliche the Hall Pass what's
that your cousin's wife's uncle fought
in Vietnam oh you must be the world's
leading authority on the history of
communism in Southeast Asia you know
using your alignments to make your point
doesn't work this whole I can't be
racist my best friend is black stuff has
been going on for a long time but thank
you for updating it and bringing it
online just a shame it's never worked
and it never will but I'm sure you know
all about never working because you want
to talk to a homeless dude at a bus stop